Uno de mis personajes de dibujos animados preferidos es Snoopy.
Me encanta la forma en la que se acuesta en su caseta y medita sobre las grandes cosas de la vida
Así que cuando pensé sobre la compasión,
mi mente inmediatamente me llevó a una de esas viñetas
donde está tumbado, y dice:
"Verdaderamente entiendo y aprecio
que uno deba amar a su vecino igual que uno se ama a sí mismo.
El único problema son los vecinos. No los aguanto."
De alguna manera, ésta es una de las dificultades
de cómo interpretar una buena idea.
Pienso que todos creemos en la compasión.
Si uno observa las principales religiones del mundo,
encontrará enseñanzas acerca de la compasión.
En el Judaísmo, la Torá nos enseña que
debe amar a su vecino como se ama a sí mismo.
Y dentro de las enseñanzas judías y rabínicas, tenemos a Hillel,
que enseñó que no debe hacerle a otros lo que no quiere que le hagan a usted.
Todas las religiones principales tienen enseñanzas similares.
Nuevamente, dentro del Judaísmo,
tenemos una enseñanza sobre Dios
al que se llama El Compasivo, Ha-rachaman.
Después de todo, ¿cómo podría existir el mundo sin que Dios fuese compasivo?
Y como nos enseña la Torá, fuimos hechos a imagen y semejanza de Dios,
por lo que también nosotros debemos ser compasivos.
Pero ¿qué significa? ¿cuál es su impacto en nuestra vida cotidiana?
A veces, evidentemente, el ser compasivo
puede generarnos emociones difíciles de controlar.
Sé que muchas veces, cuando oficio un funeral,
o cuando me siento con los familiares de un difunto o con moribundos,
me abruma la tristeza, la dificultad,
por el desafío que afronta la familia, por la persona.
Me emociono hasta el punto en que se me llenan los ojos de lágrimas.
Y si sólo me permitiese a mí misma abrumarme por estas emociones,
no estaría haciendo mi trabajo
porque realmente tengo que estar ahí para esas personas
y asegurarme de que se cumplen los rituales y los aspectos prácticos.
Pero por otro lado, si no sintiese esta compasión,
creo que sería la hora de colgar la toga
y dejar de ser rabina.
Estas mismas emociones nos llegan a todos mientras nos enfrentamos al mundo.
¿Quién no siente compasión
cuando ve los horrores terribles de los resultados de la guerra,
el hambre, los terremotos o los tsunamis?
Conozco a algunas personas que dicen:
"Sabes, hay tanto ahí fuera que yo no puedo hacer nada.
Ni siquiera voy a empezar a intentarlo."
Algunos trabajadores de ONGs denominan esto "fatiga de compasión".
Otros sienten que ya no pueden afrontar la compasión,
así que apagan la televisión y no la ven.
En el Judaísmo, sin embargo, solemos decir que debe haber un camino medio.
Por supuesto, usted debe ser consciente de las necesidades de los demás,
pero debe ser así de manera que pueda continuar con su vida
y servir de ayuda a las personas.
Así que para ser compasivo, debe entender qué es lo que mueve a la gente.
Y naturalmente, no puede hacer esto hasta que se entienda mejor a sí mismo.
Hay una hermosa interpretación rabínica sobre los inicios de la creación
que dice que cuando Dios creó el mundo,
pensó que sería mejor crear el mundo
únicamente con el atributo divino de la justicia.
Porque, después de todo, Dios es justo.
Por tanto, debería haber justicia en todo el mundo.
Y luego Dios miró al futuro y se dió cuenta de que
si el mundo se crease únicamente con justicia, el mundo no podría existir.
Así que Dios pensó: "No, voy a crear el mundo solamente con compasión"
Y luego Dios miró al futuro y se dió cuenta de que,
de hecho, si el mundo estuviese exclusivamente lleno de compasión,
habría anarquía y caos.
Debe haber límites para todas las cosas.
Los rabinos describen esto como ser como un rey
que tiene un cuenco precioso y frágil, de vidrio.
Si introduce demasiada agua fría en él, se hará añicos.
Si introduce agua hirviendo, se hará añicos.
¿Qué debe hacer? Introducir una mezcla de ambas.
Así que Dios otorgó al mundo ambas posibilidades.
Pero también debe haber algo más
y eso es la traducción de los sentimientos
que podemos tener sobre la compasión,
al mundo, en un sentido más amplio, a la acción.
¿Saben? No podemos simplemente tumbarnos ahí como Snoopy
y pensar grandes pensamientos sobre nuestros vecinos.
Realmente tenemos que hacer algo al respecto.
Dentro del Judaísmo también tenemos esta noción de amor y bondad
que se convierte en algo muy importante.
Luego, estas tres cosas se deben unir.
La idea de la justica, que pone límites en nuestras vidas
y nos da un sentido para saber lo que está bien en la vida y en la forma de vivir,
qué debemos hacer, justicia social.
Debe haber voluntad para hacer buenas acciones,
pero naturalmente, no a expensas de nuestra propia cordura.
En el fondo no conseguirá hacer nada por otra persona
si intenta hacer demasiado.
Equilibrar todas las cosas en un punto medio es la noción de la compasión,
que debe existir, por así decirlo, en nuestras propias raíces.
Este concepto de la compasión nos llega
porque estamos hechos a imagen y semejanza de Dios,
que es, a fin de cuentas, El Compasivo.
¿Qué conlleva esta compasión?
Conlleva la comprensión del dolor de los demás.
Pero aún más que esto,
significa comprender nuestra conexión con la creación,
entendiendo que somos parte de esa creación,
que existe una unidad subyacente en todo lo que vemos,
en todo lo que oímos y en todo lo que sentimos.
A esta unidad la denomino "Dios".
y esta unidad interrelaciona todos los aspectos de la creación.
Y, naturalmente, en el mundo moderno, con el movimiento medioambiental,
nos estamos concienciando aún más sobre la conectividad de las cosas:
hacer algo aquí realmente tiene una repercusión en África,
y si utilizamos una cantidad excesiva de carbono
parece ser que estamos causando
una escasez importante de lluvia en África central y oriental.
Por lo tanto existe una conectividad.
Debo entender esto como una parte de parte de la creación,
como una parte de estar hecho a imagen y semejanza de Dios.
Debo entender que mis necesidades
a veces deben estar sublimadas a otras necesidades.
Me parece fascinante este formato de 18 minutos,
porque en el Judaísmo, la palabra, el número 18 en letras hebreas,
representa la vida, la palabra "vida".
Por tanto, de cierto modo, estos 18 minutos me desafían a decir que
en la vida, esto es lo importante en términos de compasión,
pero otra cosa también.
18 minutos realmente son importantes,
porque durante la Pascua, cuando tenemos que comer pan sin levadura,
los rabinos dicen: "¿Cuál es la diferencia entre la masa con la que se hace el pan,
y la masa con la que se hace pan sin levadura, la matzá?"
Y dicen que la respuesta es 18 minutos,
porque eso es lo que dicen que tarda esta masa en convertirse en levadura.
¿Qué significa que la masa se convierta en levadura?
Significa que se llena de aire caliente.
¿Qué es la matzá? ¿Qué es el pan sin levadura? No lo entiende.
Simbólicamente, lo que dicen los rabinos es que en Pascua,
tenemos que intentar deshacernos de nuestro aire caliente, de nuestro orgullo,
de nuestro sentimiento de que somos los más importantes del mundo,
y de que todo debe girar en torno a nosotros.
Por tanto, intentamos deshacernos de estos sentimientos,
y haciendo esto, intentamos deshacernos de los hábitos, las emociones, las ideas
que nos esclavizan, que nos ciegan, que nos dan una estrechez de miras
hasta que somos incapaces de ver las necesidades de los demás.
Debemos liberarnos de esto y liberarnos a nosotros mismos.
Esto también forma parte de la base de ser compasivo,
de comprender nuestro lugar en el mundo.
En el Judaísmo hay un cuento precioso
sobre un hombre rico que fue a la sinagoga
y él, como hacen muchos, dormitaba durante el sermón.
Mientras dormitaba, leían el libro del Levítico de la Torá
y decían que, en tiempos remotos, en el templo de Jerusalén,
los sacerdotes solían tener pan
que acostumbraban a poner en una mesa especial en el templo en Jerusalén.
El hombre estaba dormido, pero escuchó las palabras pan, templo, Dios, y despertó.
Dijo: "Dios quiere pan. Eso es. Dios quiere pan. Sé lo que quiere Dios"
y corrió a casa. Después del Shabat hizo 12 panes,
los llevó a la sinagoga, entró,
abrió el arca y dijo: "Dios, no sé por qué quieres este pan, pero aquí está."
Y los metió en el arca junto con los rollos de pergamino de la Torá.
Luego se fue a casa.
El limpiador entró a la sinagoga,
"Oh Dios. Tengo grandes problemas. Tengo hijos que alimentar.
Mi mujer está enferma. No tengo dinero. ¿Qué puedo hacer?"
Entra a la sinagoga. "Dios, ¿me puedes ayudar?
Ah, qué olor más maravilloso."
Se acerca al arca y lo abre.
"¡Hay pan! Dios, has oído mi súplica. Has respondido a mi pregunta."
Se lleva el pan y se va a casa.
Mientras tanto, el hombre rico pensó para sus adentros:
"Soy un idiota. ¿Dios quiere pan?
Dios, que gobierna el universo entero, ¿quiere mi pan?"
Se va corriendo a la sinagoga. "Lo sacaré del arca antes de que alguien lo encuentre."
Entra, y no hay nada.
Y dice: "Dios, realmente lo querías. Querías mi pan.
La semana que viene, pan de pasas."
Esto continuó durante años.
Cada semana, el hombre llevaba pan de pasas,
con todo tipo de cosas buenas, y lo dejaba en el arca.
Cada semana venía el limpiador: "Dios, has vuelto a oír mi súplica",
y se llevaba el pan a casa.
Esto continuó hasta que llegó un rabino nuevo. Los rabinos siempre lo arruinan todo.
El rabino entró, vió lo que estaba ocurriendo
y llamó a ambos a su despacho.
Y dijo: "Esto es lo que está ocurriendo."
Y el hombre rico, ay, estaba alicaído.
"¿Quiere decir que Dios no quería mi pan?"
Y el hombre pobre dijo: "¿Quiere decir que Dios no oyó mi súplica?"
El rabino dijo: "Me malinterpretaron."
"Me malinterpretaron por completo", dijo.
"Por supuesto, lo que usted está haciendo", le dijo al hombre rico,
"es responder a la súplica de Dios de que debemos ser compasivos."
"Y Dios", le dijo al hombre pobre, "está respondiendo a tu súplica
de que las personas deben ser compasivas y deben dar."
Miró al hombre rico. Le cogió de las manos y dijo:
"¿No lo entiende? Estas son las manos de Dios."
Así que así es como yo me siento,
que únicamente puedo intentar acercarme a esta noción de ser compasivo,
de entender que existe una conectividad, que hay una unidad en este mundo,
que quiero intentar cumplir con esa unidad,
y que puedo hacer esto a través del entendimiento, espero,
intentando comprender el dolor de los demás,
pero entendiendo que hay límites, que las personas deben cargar con la responsabilidad
de algunos de los problemas con los que se encuentran,
y yo debo entender que mi energía para dar generosidad
tiene límites.
Debo reevaluar estos límites,
intentar apartar las cosas materiales
y las emociones que me pueden estar esclavizando,
para poder ver el mundo claramente.
Y después tengo que descubrir de qué manera
puedo hacer que estas sean las manos de Dios,
y así traer compasión a la vida en este mundo.